about some quirks and a scale of one to
ten how much of a hurdle is this
specific quirk the ravens five straight
weeks at home
four games and a buy is that a problem
or a good thing scale of one to ten how
big of a hurdle is that i mean it's not
really a hurdle when you just you know
talk about that specific part of it so
like i'm gonna just say like it's it's a
five it's right down the middle you know
it's great again it's a little bit like
we've talked about it's gonna give them
the opportunity to have a really good
record going in their bi week in week
eight but they pay for it a little bit
on the back end yeah i mean when you
talk about the dolphins there a week 10
and then at the bears and then the
browns at home and then at the steelers
and at the browns again hey four to five
on the road pretty tough ball games
right there uh that's where they get
their payback for that
oh and by the way the browns play the
ravens back-to-back games with a buy in
between which means while the ravens are
playing in pittsburgh the browns will be
resting up
ravens right rematch which uh look
one to ten
you know the fact that the browns are
playing the ravens back to back weeks
when you consider the ravens are playing
the steelers in between one to ten how
big of a deal is this for the browns uh
yeah
it's it's better for the browns for sure
i mean it's a good thing so uh i don't
know what are we saying 10 is a good
thing or a bad thing 10 is it yeah so i
mean a bad one if you're gonna compare
you know them to what the brave ones got
to do i mean i'm gonna say it's it's a
good thing it's it's like a two on the
on the richter scale there i mean first
off i love it i'll just say that i do
that's you know we've talked about this
a lot through our time together anytime
you play a team two out of three weeks
right like even with like the the ravens
with that game sandwiched in between
it's still gonna be personal you know
just you could still have those personal
feelings from that game you played
now the browns are gonna be like extra
personal it's going to be like wait
we're going to work all week to study
and play you then we're going to play
you we're going to have a bye week we're
going to go back and watch what we did
against playing with you and then also
start studying so we're going to play
you one more time and that's where yeah
it can get personal you get sick of
looking at a team everything like that
so that should be fun and you know maybe
some lamar can have some bathroom
theatrics for us again or cramping
theatrics to make it even better
and and for those of you who are too
young to remember this even though it
angers both browns fans and ravens fans
alike the ravens used to be
the browns and as more time passes more
and more people need to be
reminded if not told that for the first
time now the browns is the browns as
pete says right
next up well done pete week 14 buys we
mentioned this earlier colts dolphins
patriots eagles scale of 1 to 10 how big
of a hurdle is that i i think it stinks
so i'm gonna give it like an eight at
least there i i am just because you're
going into a a part of the year where
you're gonna be worn out you know by the
time the buy does get there and like i
said earlier today i think it stinks
because it does like let's see week 14
is is right at the start of december
right
um december 12th december 12th yeah i
mean you just to me it messes up your
late season momentum
you know anytime
again not that i was you know johnny
star starting quarterback but the teams
i was on that were in the playoffs or
anything like that it was there in like
early mid-december where you started to
feel like
damn we can beat anybody on any sunday
we gotta go and it doesn't matter you
know we're never out of a game anything
like that so you kind of mess up that
mojo
how about three straight road games for
three teams bengals cowboys colts how
big of a hurdle is that one to ten
i i think you know i'll give that a a a
seven
like that's that stinks you know seven
you know three road games in a row
that's that's not easy two road games in
a row but just that extra travel and
then depending where the games are right
i mean you know how far the travel is
everything like that yeah that that
wears on you as an organization it wears
on the coaches i think even more than
the players you know because you're
you're traveling back and you get home
late on a sunday and the coaches got to
get in there early again on monday and
then you know great film and then start
on the new game plan and everything like
that and because you were traveling and
everything like that you're behind the
eight ball so there is something to that
you know that that's one of the things i
noticed for the steelers who have a very
difficult schedule they have nine games
against teams that won 11 or more last
year they've got the ravens on sunday
late afternoon and then they play at
minnesota the following thursday night
that comes in december that's not going
to be an easy two game stretch for the
steelers how about two road games to
begin the season cowboys broncos vikings
49ers all on the road for the first two
games
uh the other good news is you got 15
games after that and uh you know the
bulk of the game is going to be home
games you got to get through the first
two and you start oweing two
you're looking at major panic coming
into week three yeah you're i mean yes
uh but i i guess i i don't look at it as
like a horrible
a horrible thing
i think i if i had to rate this i'd
probably just give it a four i mean yeah
being on the road first two weeks is not
perfect but i do think like you know if
you're gonna pick pick a time to do that
too it's not the worst the energy of the
year you know you're still fresh and
feeling good and you're excited about
all of that and then i think like you
said to button up the other element is
now we've gotten two road games out of
the way and we got you know 15 games
left and the majority of them are going
to be at home that that's the positive
there so i i don't as a player i never
looked at that and was like oh man we
don't get to play a home game till week
three um
it didn't affect me
for the broncos it'll be nine home games
in the final 15. wow three nfc teams
it'll be eight home games in the final
15. and look it depends on who you play
too yeah cowboys are at tampa and at the
chargers they quite possibly will be
owen two the other teams denver they
could beat the giants they could beat
the jaguars vikings they could beat the
bengals they could beat the cardinals
49ers they i think they will beat the
lions in the eagles and be 2-0 before
they ever play at home that gives you a
hell of a boost right right then you get
to 3-0 with that sunday night game
against the packers and you're off and
rolling yeah i mean you you're going
wait we've got two road games out we're
2-0 and now we're home a little bit we
can recharge we're gonna have a bye week
and week six you know to really make the
the big end of the year push and all
that type of thing get ready for a good
colts team i mean the 49ers yeah i mean
no schedule is easy as we've said but uh
it definitely is favorable for them to
get their feet back underneath them and
get back into the the super bowl form we
saw two years ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports